- [Voiceover] We've already
talked about the notion
that a water molecule has polarity to it.
One end has a partially negative charge,
and the other end has
partially positive charges.
And we've talked about how
this leads to hydrogen bonds,
and we alluded to the fact
that maybe these hydrogen bonds
give us all sorts of
neat properties of water.
And what I want to talk
about in this video
is one of those very important properties,
and that's water's ability to be a solvent
Water's ability to be a solvent.
And this means that it's
easy for certain things
to be dissolved inside of water.
And that's super important,
because that's how a lot
of the chemistry occurs,
by things getting dissolved in water
and then interacting and
bumping with other things.
And this is actually what's
happening inside of cells,
in the cytoplasm.
The cytoplasm, which is mostly water,
is a solvent which allows
a bunch of interactions
to happen between different
types of molecules.
But let's think about why
water is a good solvent,
and what types of things
it can dissolve easily
and what types of things it might not
be able to dissolve so easily.
So the key feature that
makes water a good solvent,
or at least a good solvent for
a large class of molecules,
is its polarity.
If I were to take some sodium chloride,
often known as table salt,
so let me...
So if I were to take sodium
NaCl, sodium chloride.
Sodium chloride, the sodium and chloride
are attracted by ionic bonds.
The sodium right over here
has a positive charge,
it has an electron stripped from it,
and the chloride has a--
let me write that in a different color.
So the sodium has a positive charge,
because it has an
electron stripped from it,
and the chloride, it is an anion,
it has a negative, it is
a negatively charged ion,
because it gains an extra electron.
But they are attracted to each other.
This has a positive charge,
this has a negative charge.
This is called an ionic bond.
But if you put sodium chloride in water,
something very interesting happens.
This is something that
we've all experienced.
Take some table salt and put it in water
and see what happens.
It will dissolve.
And why does it dissolve?
Well, let's draw it out.
So this is the sodium right over here.
So that's the sodium.
It has a positive charge.
And then this is the
chloride right over here.
It has a negative charge.
What's gonna happen if you
put it inside of the water?
Let me do that negative
charge in the green.
What's gonna happen when
you put it inside of water.
Well, you can imagine.
The negative ends of the water molecules
are going to be attracted
to the sodium ion.
So it's going to look something like this.
So you have the oxygen,
oxygen, oxygen, oxygen, oxygen,
I'm clearly not drawing things to scale,
but this'll just give you the idea.
This end of the water molecule
all has a partially negative charge.
Partially negative charge.
So it's going to be attracted
to the positive sodium ion.
And then the hydrogen ends,
the hydrogen ends,
are going to have a
partial positive charge,
and then they're going to be repelled.
They are going to be repelled
from the positive sodium ion.
So it's gonna look something like this.
And it's gonna look something like this.
And you're gonna have
partial positive charge
on the outside.
Partial positive charge on the outside.
And now these hydrogens over here,
this will just interact with water
the way that it would typically,
with the hydrogen bonding,
the molecules just
flowing past each other.
So the fact that the sodium ion here,
it's an ion, it has charge.
It is able to dissolve
in the water very easily,
because it is attracted to
the partially negative ends
of the water molecule.
Now, a similar thing is going to happen
with the chloride ion.
And we call a negative ion an anion.
So over here, over here,
and actually let me get some,
let me move it over a little bit
so that I have some space.
So the chloride anion,
let me move it over a little bit.
So right, or maybe I'll move it over here.
So the chloride,
the chloride anion,
let me see, I'm having trouble
with my selection tool.
Alright. So there we go.
The chloride anion has a negative charge
that's going to be attracted
to the positive end
of the water molecules.
So you could imagine something like this.
So the hydrogen ends, the hydrogen ends,
are going to be attracted to it,
they have a partially positive charge.
They have a partially positive charge.
And of course you have the oxygen end
that has a partially negative charge.
It has a partially negative charge.
And I could draw more of these.
Hydrogen, hydrogen,
attracted there,
you have the oxygen over,
let me do that, I wanna
keep my colors consistent.
The oxygen right over there,
we have the hydrogen,
once again this isn't drawn to scale.
Hydrogen, it is bonded to the oxygen.
And so once again, you can form this,
so you could almost imagine
this shell of water molecules
is going to be attracted to it,
it's going to be attracted,
or I guess you could say
the partially positive end,
which is where the hydrogen atoms are,
is what's going to be
attracted to this negative ion.
So this is partial positive over here.
And then on the partially negative side,
outside of this shell,
you can imagine it's just
gonna interact with the water
just the way any water molecule would,
and so it's gonna be
able to flow very easily.
So you probably see
something interesting here.
If something has charge,
if it's an ion,
or if something has some polarity,
it's very easy to dissolve
it inside of water.
And in this case, and just to
have some terminology here,
in this case, water is the,
water is the solvent,
so water is the solvent.
So the solvent is water.
And the thing that's being
dissolved in the water,
we call that a solute.
So we call this the solute.
So the sodium chloride.
That is, you could use
sodium chloride as a solute,
or you could say that the
sodium ions are a solute
and so are the chloride ions.
That is also considered to be the solute.
And so you say, well what
kind of things dissolve well?
Well, things that that have
charge or that are polar.
And things that are charged and polar
and tend to dissolve well in water,
there's another word we use for them.
We say that they are hydrophilic.
So we could say that this
right over here is hydrophilic.
And if you look at the word root,
hydro is referring to water.
So hydro is referring to water.
And philic means loving.
So this literally means water loving.
Water loving.
Hydrophilic.
And so you might be asking, okay,
everything we've talked about,
you know, we've seen water molecules,
that's polar, we're
looking at charged ions,
okay we could get that,
we can get why they'd be hydrophilic,
they can incorporate
themselves well into the water,
but what are examples of things
that would not incorporate
themselves well in water?
Well, in general, things
that don't have charge,
or that aren't polar, aren't
going to be able to dissolve
in water all that well.
And a good example is hydrocarbons.
So if you took some hexane.
And hexane is a major
constituent of car gasoline.
So hexane, hex the
prefix means six carbons.
So let's see, one,
let me do this in another color.
So we have one, two, three,
four, five, six carbons.
So one two three four five six carbons.
And then all the other
bonds are with hydrogens.
So let me draw this as well as I can.
Carbon, at least typically,
forms four bonds.
So hydrogen, hydrogen, hydrogen, hydrogen,
hydrogen, hydrogen, hydrogen.
This right over here is hexane.
This thing has no polarity to it.
It doesn't form hydrogen bonds,
it doesn't have any polarity.
And so if you were to take hexane
and throw it into water,
it's not going to dissolve that well.
It's actually going to kind bead up.
And you would see that
if you actually threw
some gasoline inside of water.
So things like hexane we
would call hydrophobic.
Hydrophobic.
So this right over here is hydrophobic.
It'll literally ball up
to avoid getting in touch,
to minimize its contact with water.
Because the water is attracted to itself,
and it is not so attracted to
this stuff right over here.
And hydrophobic?
You still have hydro, meaning water,
and then phobic, it means fearing.
So this right over here is water fearing.
That's why it's hard to mix
things like water and oil
or gasoline and water.